l'
le premier coup brillant du championnat
du monde d'échecs malmener les deux
premiers jours par népomaties numéro un
chinois a d'abord retrouvé des couleurs
en obtenant la nul avec les Noirs un
troisième partie avant de signer un
réveil fracassant dans la quatrième avec
les pièces blanches dans cette position
les pots vient de gaffer en faisant
cavalier des 4 il a fallu moins d'une
minute à son rival pour jouer le plan de
panache pour prendre des cartes
sacrifice de qualité après quoi son
propre cavalier la briller de mille feux
au cœur de l'échiquier il se transforme
une véritable pieuvre dont les
tentacules vont totalement asphyxié les
Noirs malheureusement pour nepo on se
rend compte que ces quatre pièces
restantes se retrouvent confinées dans
une triste petite boîte de trois quatre
sur quatre une maison d'autre choix que
de rendre très vite du matériel et
ensuite le résultat est que les Blancs
un pion a une case de la dame ce n'est
plus qu'une affaire de technique pour
l'emporter sur dame fuite mais pour a
rendu les armes il aurait pu tenter de
tourger vite pour contrôler la huitième
rangée et dim aurait pu se faire plaisir
avec un dernier petit sacrifice de dames
et après tour D8 une nouvelle fois le
pion est inarrêtable et les blancs